do you think that a lot of modern women
these days have like kind of crazy
expectations of the guys they're dating
what do you think about that
happy living that
they set themselves up for a type of
lifestyle that when they meet someone
now they think that they're entitled for
that person to give them that lifestyle
but it's not up to that person it's up
to them you've got to keep up with what
you're giving yourself it doesn't matter
about that person if you can speak loud
into the mic thank you well you got to
know is you gotta keep it 50 50. do you
know what I'm saying so do you believe
in 50 50 relationships that's the fact
it should be all the time yeah so so
you'd be happy that you're in a
relationship or you're with a guy like
you live with a guy and you pay 50 of
the bills down the line everything yeah
and you'd fully respect him yeah and if
he ain't got it and I've got it I've got
it and that's it and then when he when I
ain't got it and he's got it
so what happens what happens if he loses
his job you're going to support the
whole thing yeah because if he's
goes and if we
if we give her to get that to get to
that point then he's obviously supported
me in some kind of way so I'm gonna back
my man do you think that a lot of
um your female friends would agree with
your kind of ideology nah what would
they probably say about you yeah I'm a
donut probably
that's that's crazy and then
differentiate you know what I'm saying
my head ain't like this what percentage
of your friends would probably agree
with your ideology in terms of like 50
50 down the middle everything
like just gets them up
Oh see now a lot of my friends have got
kids
okay so they'll think that they get old
more by that person but I would say
about 75 of my group would think
different from me so 25 would agree with
you yeah okay
but that's just like a mindset thing
what do you think the top what do you
think the top um on real estate dating
requirement is in your mind
the Mama's got to pay for the whole meal
I'm not gonna lie I actually got
harvested with him and that's just me
because if I'm gonna get like I see me
when I go out I'll get a load of things
I'm not expecting him for pay to pay for
all of that you know I can pay for it
myself if I ain't got the money I'm not
gonna go we can arrange it another time
it's not that deep for me that sounds
quite reasonable then
too reasonable too reasonable yeah it
might be very convenient that you say
that
anyway moving on all right so next what
like what do you think about it how do
you feel about it
um I I wouldn't
completely agree but in the sense of I
agree that relationships don't need to
be a man providing everything like a
woman never working she stays at home
like times have moved on from that women
can work women can get educated women
can go out and just as much if not more
in certain situations and that doesn't
necessarily change the facts that a man
still plays his spot and a woman still
plays her part that should be the case
however
I don't think that
we should sit there and say women are
asking too much to be treated because
back in the day use the court women
women used to be courted before you had
to you had to show to the their parents
I've got your daughter for the rest of
her life she's good now I I can take off
yeah but women were virgins then yes
that's the thing so women with virgins
though hold on hold on hold on see this
is the thing yeah okay what are you
saying what did I say you have to move
me like you talk a good game in it yeah
but at the end of the day those were
different women we're talking about
modernism it was also different yeah it
was a different Society 100 I'm not
saying that but to sit there and say
um that women are like their their
standards have now gone crazy it's it's
clear like this who like this women back
in the day was not talking about a guy
has to make six figures that didn't even
if women even hold on even if women
fought that they didn't come out all
over the place and start spewing that
kind of rhetoric that is commonplace now
so the women are different so obviously
the way they get quoted is different no
I I agree with you in that on that front
I'm just saying that if we're saying
that now the the the standards are so
much higher than they used to be that's
not the case yeah but six figures is
that that that's a huge thing but then
we're talking if if we're going if we're
going to go into the pedantics of six
figures and such we can talk about it
it's not pedantics it's numbers back in
back in the days it's like um if you
made let's say four figures is that
would have been the equivalent of six
figures now like you years and years ago
at the end of the day
hold on at the end of the day you live
in the UK yeah a highly developed
country yeah and the standard of living
is going up but the wage is not going up
so at the end of the day you have to
think with a logical brain that okay
um a lot of these people talking about
they want six figures is kind of
illogical when you think about it
because the vast majority of people do
not make six weeks do not make near six
figures that like even talking about it
is ridiculous no I I I I agree to that I
agree with that
um when I say that like I I wouldn't say
a woman's asking too much but if like
what's certain standards are we talking
about are we talking about standards
monetary-wise or we're talking about
core standards so it's a woman asking
too much when she wants the door to be
open for her or um just to go off that
point I think what is crazy okay Emmy
yeah yeah the thing what's crazy is
expecting a traditional man but not
wanting to be a traditional woman I
think that's delusion okay
you're gonna touch everything bro yo
King Richard wait just just a second but
I don't actually think women's standards
are raised I think their expectations
are raised but the standards have
dropped so like they won a lot but in
actual fact what they um actually settle
for and what they require is very low so
if you look at the fact that back in the
day you would actually have to do a lot
to actually get a good woman now it's
really just consists of maybe taking
trips actually trips is is like the
upper echelon if it actually just
involves going out
um nice places to eat nice car you know
I mean real superficial things and for
men with money that is makes it very
easy so a lot of women judge Men by how
much money they spend but a thousand
pounds to someone who actually is a
baller versus a thousand pounds or
someone who had to work 30 days in a
month it's not the same money and women
don't understand that that that I can no
that's a that's a valid point but like I
just wanted to get the yeah yeah to see
what where their levels are yeah it was
only before it was Johnny it was only
because of the expectation thing and
standards I was just like no I just
don't people like the I feel like the
expectations are way high but yeah
[Laughter]
I like my favorite thing in the world is
to spoil the guy I'm dealing with like
that I love that I love the fact that in
the sense that like buying something
that me like not even buying something
but do something that makes him realize
that someone's thinking of him because
if anything a lot of the time
women have a lot of people in their
lives that they know you're you're on
their minds all the time when you're a
daughter and this is for like privilege
like it's a privilege to have like a
father that really cares about your
mother really cares about you when
you're a man
it's it's kind of expected that you've
got you but not necessarily everyone
else has got you so I I like doing stuff
that makes someone them think like look
someone's got them now even if it's like
emotionally like men don't really
benefit in any
okay how do I put this um when people
are in relationships a woman has
everywhere to gain a lot of the time if
we're talking traditionally let's talk
about money let's talk about getting
looked after
um being able to relax a little bit more
one one important place where a man has
to gain
is someone that's going to be his peace
right and I think that's like the most
important thing that's the biggest
loyalty that look as in look but the
thing is this is another thing we put on
pedestals stuff that's the bare minimum
that is a bare minimum that is honoring
the most basic term of any relationship
any relationship is being loyal that is
honoring it I'm not going to sit there
and say I look for loyalty
you have your turn that way I'm going to
get back to you I'm going to move on to
the next guest what do you think about
it
so women's standards are definitely
going up all expectations are definitely
going up um but I do think
when you Whittle it down to the core I
just think women just want to be treated
like princesses and I do think that deep
down men want to be able to treat their
women like princesses it's just when you
hear a woman saying I want a man with
six figures one man is in that position
to do that so he won't complain and say
oh you're asking too much but it's the
man that isn't in that position that
will then feel like raw you're you're
asking for too much no do you know what
it is is that with the unrealistic
expectations is a factor you're asking
for the things that only the top 10 of
men can provide and it's unrealistic
because I mean when you go on Tick Tock
or YouTube or whatever social media a
lot of these women that are talking
about these top 10 expectations are mid
they're mid table so read and truly can
you even afford to ask for those things
really honestly deep down no but a lot
of these women they're pumped up because
if enough women say the same thing
everyone's gonna join onto the bandwagon
and I agree with you like
no I'm Gonna Let You Go yeah and the
fact that might raise majority of guys
and it's not just money it's high it's
looks his status is cloud is is a lot of
things like I roll into it's not just
money because that's just one you can
say because there's a lot of broke guys
that are six foot four that are banging
a lot of box
did you get what I'm saying so like okay
another common one oh a guy's gotta be
over six foot
um the percentage of guys are over six
foot I'm just not that high
you know what I'm saying like so that's
that's what I'm really getting at it's
just a fact of like looking at that top
10 which I understand that most women
they want to date up women don't want to
date women really don't want to date on
the same level as themselves or
definitely not below see what I'm saying
so they always want to aim up and feel
like okay he's better than me so that
raises my value because I'm with him
would you will you say that yeah no I I
do hear what you're saying women do want
to date up because again it goes back to
the idea of what we've been fed as kids
you know I mean you're reading stories
of a princess who's
lying in her bed waiting for her Knight
and shining armor to come and rescue her
and then they live happily ever after
and you don't even know what the happily
ever after looks like you know so I just
think it just comes back to what we've
been fed women just want to be
treated
well
but the way they ask for it can be a
problem as many of you know I was just
banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible